ذكرت
بانه منع الازمات من الحدوث هل لاي احد
على مستوى العالمي القدره في منع الازمات
او هذا النوع من الازمات من الحدود
حسنا اذا كنت تقصدينا ذلك على وجه العموم
فانت محقه اذا لا توجد قدره لاي شخص لمنعي
كارثه وازمه من الحدوث لكننا تعلمنا
الدروس ما سمح لنا بفهم الازمات حيث لدينا
شيء نسميه عقدا اجتماعيا عندما تنعدم
الثقه بين الناس وحكوماتهم فلا يصدق هذا
الطرف والطرف الاخر بما يدفع الصعوبه الى
النائب نفسي عن مؤسسات الدوله فذلك يعني
انذارا مبكرا على كوننا في وضع يرجح فيه
بصفه عاليه تحدث ازمه او نزاع ربما بسبب
تنافسا عرقي او خلاف دينيه او خلافات
تاريخيه بشان الاراضي كل هذا يمكنك توقعه
وبالتالي التحذير في تقارير واقتراح حلول
او غيرها وقد
ركزت جزءا من مداخلتي في منتدى الرياض
الدولي الانسانيه على كيفيه التوقع بشكل
افضل اثناء الازمات الطارئه بما يسمح
بتجنب النزاعات وبكيفيه مبسطه جدا فان
الاستثمار في التنميه يبدو هو الوسيله
الانجح لتلف الازمات والنزاعات حيث يمكنك
دائما منعها كما انه ايضا السبيل الامثل
لتجاوز الازمات والخروج منها وهذا ما
يجعلنا نفهم ان انقاذ الحياه او مساعده
الناس على الخروج من الازمه ليس اهم من
منع حدوثها فقط والطريق على اسبابها افضل
ولذلك فان منح الحلول في الوقت الملائم
اهم حيث انه مثلا عندما توفر العداله بين
الجهات فانت ستكون قد تحركت بكيفيه مبكره
وملائمه بما ينزع فتيل الموقف اود ان
اسالك عندما تستمع الى تقارير تتحدث عن ان
حجم الان فاق العسكري في سنه واحده في عام
2021 بلغ
تريليوني دولار هذه الارقام الخياليه
عندما تستمع اليها بماذا تشعر
اشعر بالحزن وبالاحباط كما اشعر ايضا
باننا بذلك نهدر الكثير من الفرص تعرفين
انه على مدى التاريخ الانساني كانت هناك
حروب ونزاعات مسلحه لكن في القرن الحادي
والعشرين فان الامن البشري والامن السياسي
والامن الغذائي لا يمكنها ان تتحقق عبر
تسليح انفسنا فلا طالما راينا ان كل
الاستجابات العسكريه للازمات والنزاعات
فشلت فقط انظري لمنطقه الساحل الافريقي
مثلا ففي السنوات الاخيره تم انفاق الكثير
من الاموال هناك في مهمات حفظ السلام ولكن
ايضا في برامج عسكريه لدعم القوى الخمس
الكبرى والان ها نحن في عام 2023 والوضع
اصبح اكثر تفجرا فالموقف في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وكثير من دول الساحل صعب حيث يتنم
التطرف العنيف ينبغي علينا ان نعترف انه
في بعض الاحيان جلب مزيدا من الاسلحه لا
يحل بشكل هيكلي المشكله لذلك فان العالم
في الوقت الذي يجد الاموال لشراء مزيد من
الاسلحه بما فيها الباهض جدا فانه يفشل في
ايجادها للاستثمار في التنميه رغم ان ذلك
يسمح بمعالجه مشاكل عدم التوازن في
الاستثمار والقضاء على الميزه الاجتماعي
والخلافات التاريخيه والاستثمار في
التعليم والبنيه الصحيه امور يعد الانفاق
فيها مجزيا وله عائدات اكثر على مستوى
الحلول اكثر من الوسائل العسكريه